good afternoon everybody
no prayers today but uh the little piece
i've got to read out to you
is entitled the difference
i got up early one morning and rushed
out
into the day i had so much to accomplish
that i didn't have time to pray problems
just tumbled about me
and heavier came each task why doesn't
god help me
i wondered he answered you didn't ask
i wanted to see joy and beauty the day
toiled
on grey and bleak i wondered why god
didn't show me
he said you didn't seek i tried to come
into god's presence
and use all my keys at the lock godzilla
gently and lovingly chided
my child you didn't knock
i woke early this morning and paused
before entering the day
i had so much to accomplish that i had
to take time
to pray
members this is
welcome to the council meeting of the
december the 14th
this is the council's virtual meeting
and everyone is asked to adhere to the
etiquette
for virtual meetings as published on the
council's website
little housekeeping you have been
provided with the council's etiquette
for virtual meetings in advance
the main points are please ensure your
device is fully
charged or is charging please mute
microphones when not
speaking please indicate in the chat bar
if you wish to speak
and please only use the chat bar to
indicate your wish
to speak and for not any other purpose
when invited to address the council
please ensure your microphone is
switched on
and switch off immediately once you have
finished
please ensure you have switched off or
to silent any other devices
you have that may interrupt the
proceedings
if any member encounters i t problems
and i am aware that there have been a
few issues already this morning
problems caused causing you to drop out
of the virtual meeting they should
use your best behaviors to rejoin as
quickly as possible
should a member be unable to rejoin the
meeting they will be deemed to have left
the meeting at that point
and the meeting will continue numbers to
call should you experience any it
problems are the it help desk
on oh one seven eight nine two six zero
zero two zero
or caroline nash democratic services
manager on
zero seven nine seven six four one six
three five three
please note that the meeting is being
broadcast live and members of the public
are able to view
the proceedings a
slight change is also intended in
respect of this meeting
in the past we have had many roll calls
in respect of votes which have seemed
probably a foregone conclusion
so today we're going to try a new system
whereby
once an item has been proposed and
seconded if nobody is speaking to it or
it appears to myself
that it appears to be a fairly um
non-confronted non non-confrontational
issue
there will not be an individual vote
unless
a request has been indicated
specifically in the chat line
for such a a vote to occur
we'll see how that goes today and
hopefully that will save a little bit of
time
so now we moved on through the agenda to
the first item
apologies and i call upon the head of
the paid service to report
and take a roll call of attendance and
note any apologies for absence
counsellors by confirming you are
present you
are also confirming that you can see and
hear the proceedings
uh starting with myself david chairman
of the council councillor
tony dixon i can see and hear thank you
thank you chairman
um councillor fitter good afternoon
councillor peter here i can
uh see and hear the proceedings thank
you
counselor adam hello this is councillor
adam
i can confirm i can see and hear the
proceedings thank you
thank you chancellor [ __ ] good afternoon
councillor alcock here i can confirm i
can see and hear the proceedings
thank you councillor parker
councillor parker i can uh here and see
the
proceedings thank you we have apologies
from councillor brookbeach
so uh councillor cargill council cargill
good afternoon everybody
i can see and hear the proceedings thank
you
councillor cleve councillor cleve here i
can see and hear the proceedings
thank you uh councillor crump against
the crump here
i can see and hear the proceedings thank
you thank you
my councillor curtis how's it curtis yes
i can see and hear proceedings thank you
thank you uh councillor adam has sent
his apologies our council of field here
councillor fielding good afternoon i can
see and hear this
proceedings thank you
fleming councillor bill fleming
i can confirm that i can see and hear
all proceedings thank you
thank you uh councillor foytec council
voice yeah i can hear and say thank you
thank you thanks for council of foreman
i can confirm i can hear and see the
proceedings
thank you councillor ian freshly
actually i can hear and see thank you
councillor jenny questly
that's the journey for actually i can
hear and see proceedings thank you
thank you councillor jeffy harris
councillor harris are you with us
okay because our house is indicated in
the chat that she
is with us but we would we'll just check
the connection because we can't hear
at the moment councillor harris are you
there
hello yes good afternoon good luck to me
could you confirm that you can hear and
see the proceedings please yes i can
hear and see the proceedings
thank you council house counselor harvey
good afternoon council harvey
can see and hear thank you thank you
seraphin it's an anxious everything i
can see
and hear the proceedings thank you
council jefferson
councillor jefferson i can hear and see
the proceedings
thank you councillor jennings councillor
jennings i can hear and see the
proceedings
thank you our counselor junit
yes i can hear and see the proceedings
thank you
we have apologies from councillor
kendall uh councillor kettle
uh good afternoon councillor christopher
kettle i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you councillor mills council chris
millers i can hear and see
the proceedings thank you thank you
councillor o'donnell
thank you our counselor parry parry
yes good afternoon everybody councillor
parry here i can see
and hear the proceedings thank you
thank you councillor pemberton
good afternoon season's greetings to
officers and members
uh councillor pemberton can see and hear
the proceedings
thank you our councillor keller good
afternoon
and cancer reporter gala here i can see
and hear the proceedings
thank you council richards
cancer richards i can see and hear
proceedings
thank you councillor riley castle of
riley i can see and hear the proceedings
thank you rock councillor rock
i can see and hear proceedings thank you
council of wolf
council rolfe i can see and hear
proceedings
thank you council shinton good afternoon
councillor shenton
i can hear and see proceedings thank you
very much thank you and councilor wally
hoggins
good afternoon council wally hogans i
can hear and see
everything thank you thank you and thank
you chairman
thank you david uh item two on the
agenda
disclosures of interest i now invite
members and officers to make their
declarations of interest to the meeting
please indicate in the chat function
your wish to speak and
so declare
councillor rock you have indicated
uh thank you chairman i cannot declare
an interest pleasing
item six uh page sixty i see that
um there is an item in improving access
to the doctor surgeries in sound them
i'm the vice chairman of the patient
group
at the same austin surgery
thank you councilor uh councillor
manuela pertiguella
yeah justin um in relation to item six
a member of the seal and climate
emergency action plan working group for
laddington parish council
thank you council of foreman
thank you chairman again item six on
page
sixty with uh infrastructure list
project uh refurbishment of the greg
hall uh
by austintown council i am chair of
ulster town council
so i'd like to declare that interest
please thank you
councillor junaid
i'd like to declare an interest in the
same item
uh infrastructures funding statement
item six page sixty
i'm a member of the working group for
the greg hall as well
thank you very much council junior
uh councillor cargill has uh indicated
thank you on that same item i'm a member
of the working group
on there and the ulster town council
member
thank you
nobody else showing in the in the chat
so
that is the disclosures of interest
declared
thank you
moving on now to the the minutes
rather than take a roll call and respect
everybody agreeing that the minutes are
uh accurate
uh can uh i ask anybody who has any
issue with
them or any objections to them to please
indicate in the chat
if nobody indicates anything then i will
be signing the minutes later
thank you
thank you members
all right we now move on to
announcements and uh i'll
just make the uh the briefest of starts
again
life as a chairman is a is still a lot
quieter than
on previous occasions uh obviously since
our last meeting that has been
remembrance sunday
when we recorded the the
laying of the wreaths etc on a fine
sunny day
on the wednesday before the sunday uh so
anybody watching it uh
on the sunday when it was released might
have thought it was nice and sunny in
stratford
unfortunately like many a remembrance
sunday
it was a cloudy and dull day in the
event
there's been one civic
service so far which i've been able to
attend that was uh over in lemington for
the mayor of levington
uh and as i say very quiet life so far
but i do notice and i do welcome i see
an opportunity on
wednesday this week and my thanks goes
to paul chapman
he's organized uh a quiz and i think i
shall be uh participating
it will be interesting to see whether or
not our group and
other councillors equally well join in
this quiz
but uh thank you very much paul for uh
organizing that
and that i think is associated with the
wearing of christmas jumpers or seasonal
jumpers or what have you
so all the modern all the fun still to
come this
this wednesday uh that in actual fact
is the end of my announcements um and i
now ask
the leader councilor jefferson if he has
any announcements to make please
thank you chair uh yes
first one very simple we now have
regular meetings between the leaders
and chief executives of warwick district
council and stratfor district council
on the monday of last week i visited the
british motor museum
which was very interesting
i'd now like to move to curvy 19 if i
may
um just as a bit of background
uh so that everyone understands why we
did what we did
um the criteria
for deciding on tiers
are fairly simple and straightforward
there are five of them
uh the first indicator is the case
detection rates in all age groups the
second is case detection rates in the
over 60s
which is seen as a key driver of
hospital admissions
the third is the rate at which cases are
rising or falling
the fourth is positivity rate and the
fifth is pressure on the nhs
when they it was announced that we were
in tier three
we looked at all the data relevant to
stratfor district
and all our indicators showed towards
the
bottom end of the range indeed it was
very interesting that the financial
times produced an interesting chart the
day
after uh the tiers were announced
which showed the case detection rate in
all age groups for stratford-on-avon
was below about three-quarters of the
ones that were in tier two
so we took legal advice uh specialist
legal advice
uh the advice was that we had a case
so we decided to proceed uh i have to
say that at that time
we did not know that the leaders
of sully hill coventry and warwickshire
had written
jointly to the secretary of state for
health
asking to be considered as a single unit
i would also say that i consulted
all my portfolio holder colleagues and
the view was unanimous that given
the legal advice was that we had a good
case
we should proceed the one thing i would
add to that is that
since we took the decision to proceed
i've had
lots of emails and messages about it
and it's running about ten to one
in favor of the action we took
so i think at that point i just hope
i've
clarified what we did in terms of
starting the judicial review process
for kobe 19 chair
thank you very much councillor jefferson
uh before asking uh
mr buckland to make his announcements
what i would like to do in action fact
is to give the opposition leader leaders
uh opposition groups
and the independent members an
opportunity to also speak
on the same topic of the uh the covid
essentially so councillor junet would
you like to speak on this subject as
well
yes yes indeed um it was ex
i was extremely disappointed by the lack
of communication between the county
council
and the district council particularly
since they are all of the same
uh that they're all all the same
political party
um this this decision has
cost the council difficulty
embarrassment
and cost but it what is worrying me even
more so
is that this is at least the third time
now that there has been
problems with communication between the
county council
which has caused difficulties for the
district council
i would please ask not only that the
leader
of all councils speak to each other
regularly but that the two
those councillors that share uh both
county and district
uh at uh at the county council
particularly the
the conservative members one of whom it
has a portfolio
at the county council that they should
all
talk to each other and prevent this kind
of embarrassment happening again
it really is not good enough we are
still negotiating over whether to have
a single unitary or two unitaries which
is what the district council prefers
if we can't get these other items
correct then there doesn't seem to be
that much hope for
being able to sort out the unitary
problem either
there's another item on the pa on the um
agenda today which is the
gypsy and traveller sites that was a
problem uh
caused by lack of communication we
really must
have uh this kind of thing sorted and i
would like to know exactly what this has
cost the council
in uh in not only um
cost in money but also cost the council
in lack of them
of confidence in the members of the
public it to uh on
our decisions this is um not just not
good enough i really do
want people to talk to each other much
better than they have done so far
thank you councillor ed communication
and conversations are indeed
a very worthwhile exercise without a
shadow of a doubt
um councillor poetry uh do you
wish to uh contribute from the
independence
yeah i'd like to um well just say that
sort of
we're in the middle of a pandemic and
many residents of warwickshire
have died others with lives that have at
the very least have their lives
disrupted and others
who don't know if they've got jobs to go
back to
to have this compounded by the leader of
warwickshire county council
being a co-signatory of the letter
urging the county
to be clustered with coventry and
solihull this with anyone with
common sense would have told us that the
risk of going into a higher tier would
have been inevitable
after seeing the rates of transmission
of covid
if this wasn't bad enough um
the leader of county council had the
foresight not to tell anyone about this
letter
not her own conservative county
councillors nor her conservative
counterparts
that lead warwick and stratford district
councils
or did she inform and consult the mps
that represent the towns of the county
in fact who did she inform certainly not
counsellors here on stratfor district
council
did she inform or consult the
hospitality sector in stratford
fourth hardest hit town in the country
did she inform the pubs and restaurants
that were expecting to come out of
lockdown into tier one or two possibly
restaurants and pubs that have invested
a huge amount of money on food and drink
uh for their fully booked businesses
did she inform them that solihull and
coventry were going to go into the mix
with decision making
by the government we all know the answer
no
i find it astonishing that to make a
decision of this magnitude
and not inform our own colleagues
completely beyond belief
trust and transparency is essential in
times of national crisis
as residents we have to know and believe
our local
and national leaders are being open and
honest with us
without this trust breaks down and makes
it much harder for local residents to
believe
leaders and harder than to expect the
public to follow the rules
i hope lessons can be learnt from from
this
and that our local leaders put the
residents welfare
before any political ambitions that they
may have thank you
thank you council point jack um
councillor harris uh also
an independent did you wish to speak to
this topic at all
thank you chair no i've got nothing
further to add i do agree that the
communication has been poor
and we need to do better
thank you very much uh and uh
finally i think there's a conservative
member to speak on this one is
councillor pemberton
to speak to it please
thank you very much chair mean i
would merely observe that um um
we have been um we we have acted
uh to support our residents our economy
and our businesses uh based on a
rational
analysis of data and it was the right
thing to do
things have moved on somewhat since then
it was therefore the right thing to do
to decide not to proceed further with
the
uh the judicial review um councillor
junit is aware as our other
all other members of the cost that have
been incurred to date um
i would observe that it's um it's
impossible to quantify
things that can't be quantified but all
members have clarity about the costs
that have been incurred
and we now now must now move on
and await the update from her majesty's
government
around tiering and we will
we will react and respond to that as
appropriate
we will continue to lobby the government
at all levels to ensure that
this district this county uh is in the
correct tier
and that we can do all within our power
to support our communities to emerge
from
the pandemic and i think that uh
noting councillor ford checks comments
about trust
and support by members um i would
suggest that this is something where
we should all be on the same page uh in
supporting our communities that is the
one single and only objective of this
council is to support its communities
through this
and uh i am sure that i can count on the
or we can count on the support of every
single member
in achieving that um and that's really
um we where we are uh clear explanation
of to
why we are where we are and we move on
thank you chair
thank you very much councillor pemberton
so essentially
the the announcement was made by uh
councillor jefferson and then we've had
uh comments from the leader of the
opposition
member of the conservatives and also
those independent members who wish to
speak
um i will now ask mr buckland if he has
any announcements to make please thank
you
thank you chairman um just one simple
announcement really
we all know it's been an extremely
challenging year for the council under
these exceptionally difficult conditions
that code has brought upon us
i just wanted to thank all the staff
again for all of their efforts
over the last nine months but also all
of the councillors to your support
in your individual communities and i
wish everybody a a very happy christmas
and and please have a rest recharge your
batteries
over the festive period i'm sure
there'll be far much more to be done
in the new year thank you chairman thank
you david
uh my welcome in actual fact uh didn't
include the thanks to the staff because
essentially
i'm leaving that for the very end of the
meeting so
it will be coming
moving on now to item five public
participation
there have been three questions received
from members of the public
two questions from former councillor mr
chris saint
and one from mr mike roberts the
managing director of take flight
aviation limited
have we mr saint on the on the line
please
we don't think mr saint has dialed in
yet
whilst we wait for mr saint to
potentially dial in
have we got mr roberts on the line
it seems that neither mr saint nor mr
roberts
is currently online to uh address the
council
we'll give them both a minute or so
to try and make contact
chairman i believe you may have cut my
products on the line now
we have somebody in there but we're just
we're just trying to identify who it is
from this end
david
it's chris sanders on the line oh sorry
chris
we have councillor saint on the line can
you hear me chris
chris saint are you able to hear me at
all yes i am
uh would you like to uh pose your
question on supplementary please
yes i can hear you loud and clear tony
if you chris if you could possibly uh
mute your computer in the background it
might possibly help any feedback issues
can you then progress with your question
please sorry i'm getting two two voices
here
um
right anyway i i don't know whether you
can hear me but so chairman but
we can hear you find chris
background feedback issues
all right i'm getting two voices
chris we can hear you fine if you turn
your laptop off
and simply rely on the the phone line
it might be a lot easier for both of us
right i'm not sure how to turn the
laptop off and still keep in contact
but still anyhow
are you ready i'm not getting the
impression the chairman's right
i'm the chair is ready the council are
ready for you chris and if you just
close the lid on your laptop hopefully
close the lid
right
okay my first question uh concerns the
community infrastructure levy
i notice on today's agenda that there
are
uh there is a process for the future but
i'm interested in what's happened
since february 2018 which is in this
february coming
will be three years since community
infrastructure levy was introduced
and i'm interested in what's been
collected and what's happened to it
and that's the basis of my question
hello
thank you very much chris um councillor
pemberton
uh has a response i believe
thank you thank you chairman
um yes um uh the response has been uh
circulated to mr saint and
and two members um i take it that this
is a supplementary question from mr
saint aran spend
in previous years i will liaise with
officers to provide details from
any previous years and i will ensure
that that
response is forwarded to mr saint and
copied to
all members i would be grateful for that
because uh the response i've been given
suggests has only been one payment
i will clarify that for you mr saint and
uh
we'll i will provide you with more
detail around previous years
okay i'll wait for that to happen then
thank you
thank you very much chris now mike do
you have questions
a second question yes please um
concerns the new homes bonus
i was a bit concerned last time i
visited council
that the new homes bonus payments uh
in the um short term medium term
financial plan
had fallen to nil by 2023
24 and i couldn't find anywhere any
government announcement that this would
be the case
um now then i've been told quite
recently
and in fact on a paper that you should
have received and councillor harvey
should have received as members of the
conservative councillors association
but it was a government paper which
suggests that new house bonuses
continuing
so my supplementary question is
uh is the um is the medium-term
financial plan going to be amended to
reflect this
thank you uh chris saint thank you uh
i'll ask captain philip harvey the
portfolio holder for finance and assets
to respond please
good afternoon mr saint um
the medium-term financial strategy is as
published
it will show and it relies upon
the accurate information that new homes
bonus will
cease to exist the year after next
it will what the year after next new
homes bonus will
cease to yield a payment to the council
the year after next
on what grounds do you make that
assumption
i'm not making an assumption mr saint
i'm stating a matter of fact
well that could be disputed but still
thank you very much mr saint thank you
very much
we'll now move to mr mike roberts if mr
mike roberts is on the line i say
managing director
take flight aviation who has posed a
question
and has had the response
but now an opportunity to ask a
supplementary
uh hello can you hear me
yes uh mr roberts we can hear you fine
thank you please
please leave your supplementary uh well
you you failed to answer my
my question i put to you you've answered
no to the question
i'm asking you to justify why you are
afraid to
answer a legitimate question that's been
put to the council
i think council of pemberton mr roberts
i i have nothing to add to either of the
answers given to your questions
there hasn't been an answer but that's
the point you've answered no
i've asked you to explain very clearly
something to justify your position
and you've answered do you refuse to
answer it uh no the question is will i
will the counsellor explain how
how do i justify the position and the
answer is no
what what on what grounds can you
justify not answering a public question
i've given you my answer i'm not
prepared to engage in further discussion
about it with you mr
roberts well surely surely this is
misuse of public office
you you can't just refuse to answer a
legitimate question that's been put to
you by the public
you're running down an airfield there
that's that you were supposed to save
and these are legitimate concerns you've
given me you have a supplementary
question mr roberts please ask it
rather than that i'll ask the chairman
to move on the supplementary question is
there's been
an unambiguous breach of 2.2 of the mou
you signed
with the owners of wellspawn airfield
you've told me before that if there was
a breach
of the mou you would take actions
against the lander and this
to put that right no such action has
been taken
so please explain
um my position and the position of this
council is that we continue to be
in dialogue with the landowners as a cro
as appropriate and as required by the
mou
but you've you've
mr roberts i'm not going to answer any
further questions yeah you haven't asked
me questions
uh the supplementary has been asked
council
has provided you with the answer and
that is a
final matter in this thank you very much
mr roberts
right we now move on to uh item
gender items six minute three four seven
the adoption of the infrastructure
spending statement
2019 to 20. and i invite
councillor pemberton as the deputy
leader of the council to introduce this
item
thank you very much chairman so i'm just
waiting for my papers just to come up on
screen
sorry bear with me a second no problem
at all
so members uh the minute before you is
uh the up the adoption of the
infrastructure funding statement
and this is the mechanism by which
we establish uh transparency around the
reporting and decision making in
relation to contributions from
developers
we are required on an annual basis to
provide
and publish an infrastructure funding
statement
however members will be aware that uh
the pandemic has impacted on the
timelines for this as it has on many
other items so um we are
here talking in relation to the ifs
covering the period
1819 and therefore the
that was that then published in july
2020 which causes a consequential
delay in the production of the 1920 ifs
this will guide how we look at the next
round of allocations
and the recommendation is that the
infrastructure funding statement is
adopted
that the allocation of still receipts in
accordance with the 1920 statement
be undertaken in early 21 and based on
available still receipts
as a january 21 that the policy manager
in conjunction with the deputy leader
and portfolio holder for place
be authorized to publish any addendum to
the uh
additional and an annual addendum
apologies to the infrastructure funding
statement
setting out the parish and town council
spend for the preceding year
just to give members some clarity
because of uh the uh
the the intricacies of some of the
timing our sequence of reporting is out
is out of kilter with the requirement to
gather data from parish and town
councils
which is why there is a slight d
disconnect between the provision of the
two sets of information
happy to take any questions or comments
but other than that
uh that is the recommendation
thank you councillor pemberton uh having
proposed the
the recommendation to council i now call
upon a second for that please
councillor jennings you've indicated in
the chat that you'd like to second up
can we
you uh please address that to the
council please
yes i'll just like to confirm that to
second lab
thank you councillor jennings
does anybody wish to speak on the issue
at all i've not seen anything indicated
in the chat
if you gentlemen we have councilman and
the council of rock
indicators
councilor jr please
thank you um i just have a few comments
um
pertaining to the comment that was made
by mr saint
uh i did note that on page 55 4.5 that
no silver monies
was spent in 2019 to 20
which was a bit of interest but my main
comment is on page 56
um ulster town council had its uh was
supposed to have its referendum
on the neighborhood plan and it was
deferred as a result of kovit 19
it was due to be done in may this last
year so as as a result
this year they will only get 15 percent
of sil
monies not 25 which they would have got
if the referendum had been passed
would it be possible for this to be
refunded to ulstertown council once the
referendum is passed
presumably in 2021 and then just a
couple of other brief comments if i
might
uh on page 60 um i actually support
the flood management sub uh uh sill
monies that are going to ulster
for uh upstream review of the of the
flood and making sure that natural flood
management systems
are in place and on page 61 i would
add the comments that there is a very
successful cycle group around
ulster that is interested in putting
forward some more cycle paths
and i would urge that in future
statements that these are added to
thank you thank you would you like me to
respond
at the end yep sure
councilor rock you've indicated as well
to speak on this item
uh thank you chairman um it's in the
nature of a question
i notice on page 61 we have several
cycle track schemes and
earlier in the year before i was
indisposed i was in conversation
uh with hs2 and with
the county council to see if we could
not get a scheme together
for some cycle tracks around southern i
was told by the county council
that um they were not priorities because
the county council's policy
is not to support cycle tracks unless
they are urban
or interurban there's a couple on there
that may be an interesting
interpretation of those rules
but could i have a clarification on that
that we
that communities cannot successfully ask
for cycle tracks
unless they comply with the county
council's
policy priorities i.e urban or
inter-urban
and therefore they're never going to get
on the interstate infrastructure
list at all for that reason it seems
somewhat at odds with the central
government's
intent to improve cycling thank you
chairman
various comments please yes i um
just to actually to add what counselor
junit was saying in relation to those
um parish councils um
without a neighborhood plan again
clifford chambers and milcot
neighbor of um development plan will be
is being recommended for referendum
um obviously there's been a delay um in
relation to covid but
is now being recommended for referendum
in 2021 and i want
to know whether then the receipts um can
be
reviewed
because of their uh advanced stage thank
you
thank you councillor peter gayle
councillor crump you've indicated in the
chat
yes thank you mr chairman if it's not
too much of a problem i just
very briefly um i've got the portfolio
at candy council for road safety
which links in with highways um and
obviously we're trying to encourage more
people to to cycle
for various different reasons including
mental health
obesity uh air pollution etc
so i do fully welcome the need for cycle
tracks in
in all parts of the district not
necessarily not uh
especially in the isla district as well
where we are
there are two cycle paths that are in
the county county programme
in the southern area already and we are
looking to
to get some more in um one or two are
particularly
challenging but just that you know there
are some in the program already
and i fully support the the need for
extra
cycle pass thank you mr chairman i hope
that was okay in the informative
uh thank you councillor crump indeed it
was but i'll now uh hand back to uh
councillor councillor pemberton uh to
tackle the other topics that have been
brought up thank you
thank you chairman i think that all of
the uh the matters raised probably fall
under the uh
an exposition of the law of unintended
consequences
uh i'm certainly minded to consider with
officers
um the question of ulster if if if it is
indeed the case that
their the the the adoption and
referendum for their neighborhood
development plan
has been delayed by covid i i cannot
guarantee a guarantee because i need to
we will need to check whether there is
any latitude
given the regulations um
i'm not so clear about clifford chambers
and again
uh i would check that with officers i
think the i think the
the reality is that if if in the absence
of covered
um the relevant parish or town council
would have got to have referendum i
think that's a different thing to say
that
work has been delayed i think i i know
i'll step was
fairly close to uh to getting ready for
this
but on both i'll take that into account
and certainly as far as councilor rock
is concerned you've
you've had some indication from
councillor crump
um through the benefit of his
role at the county to give you some
assurance but again
we would not want the law of unintended
consequences to apply
and so i will task officers with
liaising further with the county council
about any policy stance they may have in
relation to
um cycling or any other matter for that
which would
almost by definition uh rule out because
in the absence of county support that
would be one of the uh one of the things
to be taken into consideration
thank you very much counselor pemberton
uh i don't anticipate that this is a
contentious issue so i don't see the
need for a roll call on this one
so the recommendations as proposed and
formerly seconded by councillor jennings
are agreed move
through now to item seven on the agenda
minute 348 public open space options for
management and maintenance
and i invite councillor kettle as the
community portfolio holder
to introduce this item
thank you mr chairman um now hopefully
this will be
uncontentious as well um the
background to this is that um
historically when you've got a
significant housing estate being built
uh public open including public open
space
that would be transferred to the local
uh
parish or town council along with a
commuted sum
uh for the benefit of the residents of
the community to enjoy
in perpetuity regrettably that
process seems to have changed over the
last few years
with public open stages being offered
through parish councils but with no
commuted sum
which clearly leaves a a liability
on residents to maintain it without the
backing
of any money from the developer
so what is happening is parish councils
have not been
necessarily taking on these public open
spaces uh and developers have been
keeping them
um transferring to a management company
um and the residents of the new estate
um then become liable to management
company
for the maintenance of the public open
space
in their immediate community
um and this causes problems it causes
problems as to who
who could use the public open space uh
versus who is paying for main
maintenance not only that uh for
residents
um there have been repeated uh comments
in the public press
that the management companies are
incurring costs in maintaining those
which
in some cases seem to know they're no
relevance to the amount of work being
done
and the words headlines have been used
fleece gate etcetera etcetera
whereby this is perceived by some to be
just an income stream management company
um on top of any benefit they the
the developer might have originally got
from selling houses
so this is a very welcome
change in policy and that is to say
that in the event the parish council is
unable
financially to take on the public open
space
that it will be taken on by the district
council uh and the district council will
then have responsibility for maintaining
those public open spaces
in the future and thereby
ensuring that the residents of the new
estates are not
um numbered with an ongoing liability
for that maintenance
but also that it is quite clear that
public open space is for the benefit of
all
not just the residents of the estate
so i'm sure all councillors will be
grateful to see this
this improvement coming through um and
um
therefore i hope everybody will want to
support this this motion um because i
think it's for the benefit of everybody
in every community in stratfor district
thank you mr chairman
thank you councillor kettle uh three
councils so far have indicated a wish to
speak
to this item uh councillor junaid first
yes can i can i welcome this um which
i it was uh i raised a question on this
in october last year so i'm glad that
it has proceeded along with support from
from obviously from other councillors
but will the councillor that council and
the leader now consider
lobbying the government for
retrospective actions
that will help local communities with
ever increasing costs
because this is only for this will only
benefit
those uh developments that are going
forward from when this
is passed but it will not apply to those
councils that were affected in the past
thank you councillor junid uh councillor
cargill
we should speak thank you very much
indeed
uh yes this is um raised well
that's part of well over a year ago with
an estate in ulster
uh with uh council foreman and
it was it immediately became apparent
this was a problem and
it was across the country
so i'm very i'm delighted that it's got
to this stage now and i encourage all
members to vote for this because i think
it's very important
picking up council jr's point although
i think the legal ramifications of
retrospective
uh changes could be problematic
but i'll leave that one for the lawyers
i am in negotiations
with a the development company in ulster
about some section 106 which has been
allocated under the
um the outline plan permissions gained
already
with the hope and it is only a hope that
perhaps we can turn that one around
and then bring them into the ownership
of the stratfor district council
so again i think for other communities
perhaps out there that are in a similar
situation
it may be worth discussing it with the
developers
and so far they've been quite keen to
engage so thank you very much chairman
thank you councillor cargill uh
councillor rock you've
indicated a desire to speak well thank
you very much chairman i like like
previous speakers are very much welcome
this step that
doesn't leave us with a maintenance
vacuum for these
spaces um as long as developers aren't
going to see it as some sort of uh
free ride for something that they might
otherwise assume responsibility for
but my specific question uh relates to
careful wording of whatever regulation
or whatever
whatever we're going to produce to
bring this into force uh i have a
particular problem
in my ward where there's a drainage
issue
in in an estate there is a pumping
station
and that and the maintenance of the
pumping station has caused us a flooding
problem which is
a long long running difficulty
would maintaining a pumping station that
is they're trying to transfer to a
management company
would that be covered by these rules
it's not quite grass cutting is it
but it would be easy to find there are
little
loopholes in how we do this
of things like that and in particular
i'd like my pumping station to be
covered
but um there may be other things that we
haven't quite thought of so
i would recommend the officers when they
come to implement this
that that gets uh gets thought about
thank you very much chairman
uh thank you council the rock uh nobody
else indicating to speak but i now need
to go back i think to councillor kettle
to uh possibly comment on those uh
contributions from those three
councillors and i think to actually
make the the recommendation to council
which i will then ask to be seconded
uh thank you councillor kettle
uh thank you mr chairman i think in
terms of retrospective
clearly if a section 106 has been signed
with the developer
um and that um this um
policy was not in place at the time then
we can't
subsequently impose it where that
section 106
uh agreement has already been reached
and signed off
but i can see no reason why we shouldn't
look to lobby
to look at government action in terms of
trying to resolve this issue because
clearly there are many many
uh developments both in this council
uh in fact there are there are three in
my own in my own ward
um where we have exactly that problem
but it is something outside our remit
we can ask but i can't necessarily
necessarily say that we as council will
be able to deliver
without um support from central
government
um in terms of the specific issue about
pumping stations etc
this is something strangely that i've
also been discussing in a
prior position uh not as a portfolio
holder
in relation to another development in my
ward
where um long discussions with officers
did highlight the challenges of pumping
stations
uh because clearly it is quite a
technical um ability to
uh respond to those but i will take the
i'll take the point forward and ensure
officers are absolutely up to speed
uh as i'm sure they already are to be
fair um but make sure that
we we take into account your concerns
which i think are well raised thank you
mr rock
councillor rock even
thank you councillor kettle uh i should
now clarify with councillor whaley
hoggins as to whether or not
she wishes to speak to item seven or
item eight which council juned was
anticipating coming along shortly
uh can you clarify that for me please uh
councillor whaley hoggins
uh no just to do the with the item that
uh council kessler is speaking on
currently
and have some helpful information please
carry on then
councillor yes it is
it is my understanding that the central
government is looking
at this very issue about these um
well i've been referred to fleece holes
so this was brought up when i instructed
officers to
sort of look at this way back very early
on in my position
on cabinet and i was assured that
central government
were looking at this um and we were
seeking some sort of clarity
from them um i can imagine that this has
been pushed back a little bit
but i it is my understanding that
national government are very much aware
of this
and know that action has to be taken
thank you
thank you very much councillor willie
hoggins if i can now ask councillor
kettle
to take take us to the recommendation
which is on page 72 of the agenda
and if that's your proposal if you'd
like to make that proposal please
councillor kettle
thank you mr chairman uh everybody you
can see the recommendation
[Music]
um on as the chairman has pointed out uh
i therefore like to recommend
that um in the event the parish or town
council decide not to take up ownership
of opportunities in public open space
in relation to any relevant planning
permission granted after first of
january 2021
the stratfor navy district council will
generally take ownership of the land
and responsibility for maintenance and
that this be adopted as part of the
council's
policy framework i propose that mr
chairman i'd be very grateful for
secondary
um and hopefully it will not be a
contentious proposal
thank you very much councillor kettle
councillor cargill i think has indicated
to second as has councillor juned
uh councillor cargill was first to uh to
that one so
council cargill yes i would delight uh
delighted to
second this proposal thank you chad
uh thank you very much councillor
cargill i've just been pointed out to me
that uh council where hoggins is also
seconded
so unless anybody else wishes to
regard it as a contentious issue i think
this is another item which we can
proceed without an indicated vote
but i will just pause for a moment to
indicate if anybody wishes to indicate
in the chat
that they don't that they think it's
contentious
nobody is indicating in the chat not
contentious therefore the recommendation
is
agreed moving through to item
eight on the agenda and i invite which
is the
waste and recycling proposal minute 349
and i invite councillor shenton as the
operations portfolio holder
to introduce this item thank you
thank you mr chairman uh all members
have had the
opportunity to attend briefings led by
julie lewis
or myself on the one two three plus
waste and recycling proposal
the presentations have been made
available to all councillors with a
further
presentation to the osc i'm grateful for
various members supportive comments on
this
in addition i've had a very constructive
meeting with the leader of the lib dems
councillor susan junid where we
discussed and recognized the benefits
of this proposal and again i'm very
grateful for her time
i don't intend to go into great detail
on this proposal
will gladly answer any questions when i
finish
my brief outline as the combination of
the cabinet papers and
on pages 73 and 74 of today's papers
plus the powerpoint presentations that
have been made
will hopefully have given members more
than enough detail
the proposal seeks to create a joint
procurement process
and eventually a contract with warwick
district council as a partner
a sign of our ever closing ever closer
working relationship
which should benefit the residents of
both districts
the proposal has already been accepted
by the full council at warwick district
council
the new count contract if agreed will
commence
in august 2022 some 19 months hence
but it is essential that we start the
process now
it is a fact that our recycling rate at
around 60 percent and wire district
council at around 55
are well ahead of the government's
target of 50 percent
by this year by moving to a one two
three plus approach with weekly food
waste collections
two weekly recyclable recyclable waste
collections and three weekly
residual waste collections we hope to
build on the great efforts already made
by our residents
we will help and encourage greater
recycling through a media and messaging
campaign
to make recycling easier to understand
and do
the benefits of increased recycling
levels reduced
levels of waste going to landfill
separate food waste collections more
effective efficient refuse vehicles
and a reduction in mileage traveled
through smarter routing especially
on the border between warwick and
stratford districts
this definitely helps to address and
takes into account the climate emergency
agenda
as mentioned just part of the proposal
includes introducing a weekly
food waste collection service ahead of
the government mandating this
as it surely will over the coming years
or over the next two or three years the
food waste will
therefore not enter the residual
recycling or greenway streams
instead we are aiming to send this to an
anaerobic digester
further removing harmful greenhouse
gases from landfill
food waste in particular releases
methane gas
when decomposing and is up to 35 times
worse than co2 for our climate
i hope the members will acknowledge that
this proposal is a big step in reducing
harmful greenhouse gases from our waste
streams
and reducing knox and co2 emissions from
our refuse vehicles
by using the latest most efficient
vehicles that are capable
of being potted to take food waste
separately
no matter which type of other waste is
being collected that week
this proposal is good for the
environment as well as mitigating the
inevitable increase
in gate fees and waste disposal costs
when the current contract expires in
july 2022
and continues our aim to improve the
carbon footprint
of each and every home in a practical
way
if the recommendation on page 74 of your
papers is approved by
councillors we'll be sending out a
message that we are committed to being a
responsible
and forward-thinking council a council
that is committed to the environment and
our residents alike
i therefore ask members to approve the
recommendation
that set out on page 74 of your papers
i am obviously happy to take
any questions
thank you mr chairman
thank you very much uh
councillor shenton i apologize um
we already have uh speakers please uh
councillor junaid to speak please
yes um i'd like to thank our head of
community and operations for the work
done on the proposal so far because i i
know how difficult that is
but just just to go through this a
little bit in detail
uh the one in this proposal is for the
weekly collection of food waste and i
support it as
do my group the breakdown of food and
other biodegradable waste contributes to
climate change emissions and we know
that householders throw
away 6.6 million tons of food waste a
year
and we also know that an entire load of
recycling can be rejected
if there is contamination by food waste
and that reduces the value of recyclable
materials
so that is not contested the two in this
proposal is for a recycling collection
every two weeks
and again i support that it reduces the
need for raw materials which are in
short supply
it reduces plastic waste which pollutes
rivers and seas
and it makes prod and making products
from recycled materials requires less
energy than making them from new raw
materials
is also cheese per to dispose of
recycled waste and general refuse
the three in this proposal refers to the
three weekly collection of residual
waste
there are three weekly collections first
it was first introduced by falkirk
council in 2015 and 15 other areas are
doing these
three weekly collections in 2019 and i
believe that somerset waste per
partnership is moving to the three
weekly
residual waste collection in 2020
and mid devon is due to vote in january
they are all saying it cuts residual
waste increases recycling and cuts
costs but there needs to be a number
four
in these proposals all of these councils
all the research that i've looked at all
stressed the need for
good communications before changing the
service particularly on the three weekly
element of it
all say recognizing what it means for
householders is an
absolutely essential component public
support is absolutely vital to success
listening to residents is important and
how householders view
their local service has a major impact
on participation now as the vice chair
of the ovu
scrutiny committee i want to see a
robust business case
the detail of an appropriate and strong
communication strategy
and i want that to come to the overview
and scrutiny committee
i want to see that we will deliver an
improved quality of service
a poorly planned or rushed service with
inadequate detail
given to performance and communications
will undermine confidence
i want to know more again again through
the ovum scrutiny committee procedures
about the policies and the costs of
meeting the needs of larger families
and those with health care needs i
disagreed on having concession
on not having concessions on the green
waste charge and it's unfortunate that
the green waste is again in this
proposal today as i didn't support that
charge originally
the government wants all councils
english councils to provide a weekly
collection of food waste by
2023 and they've claimed that they will
be giving funding to those authorities
they've stated that they will allow them
sufficient time to adapt
and to communicate changes with
householders
they've stated that they recognize the
financial pressures local authorities
face and will ensure that the costs
arising from new statutory duties will
be covered
but i want to see that this will be
delivered and again it's a matter for
overview and scrutiny
i also want to see the part that
anaerobic digestion
and composting plays in recycling food
and garden wastes
and for these reasons i'll be abstaining
on voting for these proposals
as i need to be free to ask those
questions at overview and scrutiny and i
believe that it is
our part to be a proper scrutinizing
organiza
scrutinizing party so that that means
that we will not be
supporting but we will not be opposing
these procedures going forward because
we want them to see them be
scrutinized throughout scrutiny
thank you councillor junaid uh
councillor olcock has indicated please
thank you mr chairman um yes uh as
councillor i have been speaking to
residents concerning this
or and also concerning the green bin
charge which i did not support
now how residents are seeing this is
we bring in a green bin charge which
they don't support either
and many of them reacted to well
actually i don't have a garden i don't
need my green bin
and now here we are bringing in a motion
that
means that they'll need their green bin
if they wish their food waste to be
collected more than once every three
weeks
now i can understand i've understood the
principle of this because i've had the
training
because i've sat through the powerpoint
i've sat through the the
um details that have been given to us as
counsellors
but the residents haven't had that now
what the residents are seeing
is that at the same time we bring in a
green bin because they only had
the leaflet for the charges etcetera
a few weeks ago without bringing in
saying actually you're going to need
your green bin because if you want to
get rid of food waste
this isn't a time when faith in us as a
council
is actually shockingly low
we need to make sure that for our
residents we are
taking the correct steps the correct
steps have to include informing our
residents
before we go ahead as a council to vote
this in
making sure that the count that our
residents are aware of why
we are doing this it is for the climate
change it is going to make a big
difference there but we have to give the
residents the information on why
currently it is not looking good for
this council
on why we are doing it i've had several
phone calls from my residents who are
asking why
you are charging for green bins and then
take then putting grey bean collection
down to three weeks and that is how it
is seen
by residents so yeah i will be
abstaining until i see
exactly how we are going to get this
important information
through to the residents of
stratford-on-haven
thank you council royal [ __ ] uh
councillor patogella
yes i agree with councillor olga and
council junaid a good communication
strategy is fundamental
but um also wanted to ask whether the
proposal will look at the size of the
refuse
and recycle lorries in relation to the
topography
of our local villages because um some of
the
large lorries um that are being used
are not suitable for our single truck
lanes
and and streets so i mean this morning i
witnessed um a refuse lorry going over
our um grass verge in our conservation
area
um so you know i'm just wondering
whether this is something that would be
looked into and considered um
you know and whether there's going to be
different sizes of lorries for
our different villages thank you
thank you councillor pettigella uh
councillor pemberton please
i'm not really sure where to start
just to be clear i was just moving my
microphone i'm not really sure where to
start with all this
so i'll probably go in reverse order um
how dim do you think we have to be to to
suggest that we might order lorries that
aren't going to fit
um the one thing we can't control is the
quality of the driver and i'm sorry i
don't care how good overview and
scrutiny it is
it isn't going to get us to get better
drivers the wagons that we use
do work for where we live and so i'm
sorry about that
um overview and scrutiny again you're
going to scrutinize the obvious
who thinks we're not going to undergo a
communications exercise
i'm just struggling with that and as for
casler alcock
job description 101 it's your job to
explain to your residents you've had the
training you just told everybody you
understand all of this
and you're sat there telling me you're
not gonna explain to your residents how
this flies when you support it
um absolutely we should
scrutinize the decisions but can we just
um
think about what we're actually saying
here you've got a number of people
saying
i broadly support this thing um there
might be some stuff at the margins
there's some detail i want a little bit
more of but now you're all going to say
i'm going to abstain on it um
when we had a climate change emergency
debate some months ago
i'm sure i remember saying to everybody
in this virtual room that we're all
gonna be able to make some really tough
decisions and i'm afraid
things like moving to three two one are
change and they are difficult
i'm really struggling but you know there
comes a point at which you've got to
start thinking about
explaining to your residents that there
are tough choices to make about lots of
things
um and to say you've had the training
but you you can't then relay that onto
your members
uh i it doesn't matter how good our
comms exercises if you as a
if you all as individual members are
unable to explain to your residents
after you've had the training
i think we've all got some i think we've
got some questions to ask ourselves
thank you councillor pemberton uh
councillor jefferson
and i shall mention that uh i would
expect the portfolio holder to come in
last
uh councillor jefferson thank you chair
i noticed the words in the
recommendation
adopted policy framework
what we've had a number of inputs on now
is degenerating into the details
that can actually be worked through
once we actually made the policy
decision
uh there is no point working through
that detail until we made the policy
decision
there is some way to go on this and i am
sure the communication strategy
will be put in place but at the moment
it is a policy decision
and there is clear support for this
policy decision
so i am somewhat baffled by the
abstention of many of the members that
have already spoken
abstain on a policy decision because you
can't work out the details
i think that is remarkably strange
thank you thank you councillor jefferson
uh councillor shenton uh to to wrap this
one up and then i'll be uh
seeking uh a secondary to the proposal
that you've already laid before council
thank you mr chairman um to say i'm i'm
absolutely astounded
that the lib dems should actually at
this point
come up with a load of questions that
delve into detail
rather than the strategy of this is
incredible
you've had plenty of time since the
presentations
if you had difficulties or questions
to abstain purely because of the detail
in the presentations we made clear that
there would be a communications
and media policy and approach to this
we would educate people that was in the
presentation there'd be plenty of time
for members to ask me
or julie lewis further questions
today i've not received one question
from one liberal
democrat on this in fact in the
conversation that i had with
councillor juned some weeks ago the
indication was that this would be
supported
how you cannot support something that is
good for the environment
is incredible so counselor orca
your your compass your uh question over
communication we've dealt with that
that the green bin charge i haven't this
is not part of this proposal we've
already done the green bin charge
we have to move on cancer
together the size of lorries yes
quite clearly as councillor pemberton
has indicated we will look at
this we're looking at whether the type
of lorry
how it's powered the the emissions
all of this is part of the detail of the
contract and we've made this clear in
presentations
as well so i am i'm i
sit here absolutely astounded and
amazed that that you you sit there
and you will abstain on such an
important
proposal i don't think i can add any
more to to what's being said
um i just i i've flabbergasted
that i have to say that you should ask
such obvious questions that are
detailed and part of a contract and not
think of the strategy the
overall aim of this policy this is a
policy
framework so with that chair i will i
will wrap up
and and and ask for the recommendation
to be put forward
uh as it stands thank you councillor
shenton
before going to caps the fielding to
second it i see that council junior has
requested an opportunity to clarify
councillor junaid yes and can i just
make it quite clear that
on broad principles particularly on the
point one and the two
and quite a lot on point three i have no
problems but i have been in this pr
in this uh um field of work
professionally so i
have a lot of knowledge but i have also
seen
a lot of failures caused by um making
not
making sure that the communication
strategy is is properly thought through
and that has to be thought through
almost as soon as that the tender goes
out to proposal
i've worked a long time with commercial
waste
as pilot projects where i've seen the
failures that have been caused by lack
of
communication so i'm only asking i'm
making sure that i reserve my position
as overview and scrutiny
vice chair that i will have to ask
questions on this matter
thank you thank you councillor junaid
councillor shenton
to make a comment and then i'll she'll
go to cancel the field into second thank
you
well there there we have it councillor
junior you have said
that in principle you you agree with a
lot of this and yet you're going to
abstain
and nobody say that osc can't ask
questions
nobody said osc can't ask questions no
and the communications program was
clearly laid out
in the presentation
thank you thank you thank you
councillors uh
councillor fielding i think you've
indicated that you will set under
proposal
i'm very i'm very happy to second the
proposal as
former vice chair of overview and
scrutiny
we always looked at it as looking as it
at an overview
not to the degree of scrutiny that i
think is going to come forward
but i'm very happy to second in
thank you councillor fielding uh given
the nature of this topic
i we will have a roll call of members so
you'll be
for the uh recommendation or against
recommendation or abstain i'll start the
ball rolling chairman of the council
council
tony dixon four
thank you chairman um councillor peter
councillor fitter for
thank you counselor adam
councillor walcott councillor [ __ ]
abstain
thank you councillor parker here's the
back of
four thank you hi councillor cargill
council cargill iv thank you councillor
cleve
councillor cleve abstain thank you uh
sorry cancer crump for thank you thanks
for coming
uh council curtis council of the curtis
abstain
thank you our councillor fielding
councillor fielding
four thank you uh councillor fleming
council fleming four thank you
councillortic
councillor foytec for thank you mr
foreman
councillor foreman four thank you
councillor ian frenchly
cancer influentially abstain thank you
councillor jenny frenchly
stay thank you
harris councillor harris
councillor harvey council harvey four
thank you councillor henshaw seraphin uh
council ancient seraphin epstein
thank you councillor jefferson
councillor jefferson
four thank you councillor jennings
councillor jennings for
thank you councillor junaid
thank you councillor o'donnell
councillor donald four donald four thank
you
councillor parry harry councillor parry
four thank you councillor pemberton
council of pemberton for thank you
council
council abstaining thank you
uh councillor richards cancer richards
for
thank you council o'reilly
council riley are you there
i'll come back to castle earlier in a
second council rock
hoggins councillor wally hoggins for
thank you councillor riley are you there
now
as i'm coming okay kevin are you four
against you're abstaining in relation to
the recommendations
yeah perm four you're full thank you
chairman i made that 22 votes for with
11 abstentions and therefore
the the recommendations carry thank you
thank you david moving through to
item nine on the agenda audit and
standards committee
three minutes really for the electoral
review working group
and i invite councillor crump as the
chairman of the audit and standards
committee to introduce
this item thank you mr chairman
hopefully i'll keep this relatively
brief
this is i think it's a relatively
straightforward paper that was agreed
at gordon standards on the 23rd of
november 2020
and again a lot to pass on my thanks to
the
electoral review working group that um
did all the hard work behind this and
obviously as chair of audit and
standards i'm coming in and taking all
the credit
assuming people want to give me the
credit for this
um it's pretty self-explanatory there's
one or two
smallers that were picked up and i think
one of them said increase the
the numbers by between 41 and 43
and i think it was picked up and it was
increased the numbers
2 41 and 43 and i can see mr buckland
thinking
where are we going to pay for these
extra 41 to 43 councillors
um but no we did spot that one david so
hopefully we'll put that one
um um hopefully people uh members will
agree to the recommendations which were
that the preferred number of cancers be
between 41 and 43
and that the site that the council
submission document
has attached be approved subject to any
amendments to be agreed
the chairman of the community chairman
electoral review working group executive
director and the head of law and
governance
uh happy to take any questions uh and
again
i think the other issue as well is about
the the workload as well
for the councils which has increased
tremendously
since we went down to 36 councillors so
i'm happy to take any questions or if
not
go to the recommendations thank you
thank you council crump uh can i call
for a second
please to that recommendation that is
shown at the foot of page 75.
they're coming in thick and fast i think
counselor
kettle was possibly first with a second
air
uh councilor kettle
uh well thank you mr chairman i chaired
the working group i recommend the
um council trump proposal uh to all
councillors
and hopefully this will be yet another
non-contentious item
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
councillor kettle
uh on the basis it is non-contentious i
shall just wait a few moments whilst
uh give everybody the opportunity to uh
enter anything into the chat
but other than that if there's nothing
appears we shall take it as an agreed
recommendation
nothing in chat apart from lots of
people who
are slower than capsular kettle to
second the item
so item nine is agreed is the chairman
hiding himself
i'm not aware that i'm hiding myself i
can see myself quite happily here
uh accounts for the council of fielding
and
um
essentially uh item 10 on the agenda the
calendar of meetings
um and i can't solve councillor trump as
the chairman of the audit and standards
to introduce this
uh castle crap another contentious item
mr chairman um again we looked at
the calendar of meetings and tried to
make them
with the help of community services
staff
as family friendly as possible
and we've put in a two-year program uh
with the second year program
being provisional um again happy to take
any questions
and thanks again thank the officers for
all their hard work on this thank you
councillor crump
uh uh proposing or recommending two
council those two uh
items on page 103.
so i'll call for a seconder
cancer fight check do you wish to speak
on this item
yeah it's just um thank you chair um you
don't have a problem with the calendar
um just mindful that um
uh of the comment of family friendly
i'm not sure two o'clock council full
council meeting at two o'clock on a
monday afternoon
is particularly family friendly um
perhaps that's something that can be
looked at at some point in the future
but
just something i just wanted to um pick
pick you up on that thank you like
against the fight check
i think it's probably down to the
members uh
when they look at their diaries to
determine the timings of their committee
meetings etc
on the uh the annual general meeting um
because certainly timings can be
a bit of a uh not a mystery but
certainly a concern for some councils
without a shadow of a doubt
um i see councillor bark as indicated in
second but
uh councillor alcock has wishes to speak
casserole [ __ ] thank you chair i would
actually like
the the timings of especially for
council meetings to be looked at please
um as council foreign said two o'clock
on a monday
um when you do have a young family
i mean i've had to arrange school pick
up somebody else to go and pick my
children up today
um and now because council meetings do
are taking longer it seems um
it can meetings will go on could go on
easily till six o'clock
um and again that's also not exactly
family friendly for what we are trying
to do here not just for the councillors
who are sitting
in the actual meetings but also for our
residents
who are also trying to follow what we're
doing especially doing up following
online so i would like to ask that
possibly um full council especially
the timings are looked at to make them
more
more accessible for more people
thank you council rollcock um certainly
i'm aware that uh
since uh the elections in may last year
we've now been here at 18 months for my
return visit to these
chambers and certainly i know during
those 18 months we have had
an opportunity and we were canvassed
by committee services as to what we
actually wanted
and the final result of that was that no
changes were
agreed or were wished for by the
majority
as such we are where we are but
certainly obviously those comments can
be born in mind
when we come to agree the final numbers
if you like in 12 months time
for the year 22 23
so it's been counts with joe barker has
indicated in the chat
i call on councillor barker to propose a
second thank you
having having been rather keen on
changing the timing of meetings myself
i'm very happy to second it because i
think we've gone as far as we can thank
you
thank you councillor parker uh i don't
think this is a contentious issue so
essentially we'll regard the uh the
minute 385 calendar of meetings
as i've just been
advised that counselor trump wishes to
respond uh castle crumb
obviously um i've tried to keep my um
items as brief as possible
so not to drag the meetings out for too
long
um but certainly um we'll
i think we're confusing things here we
were trying with the calendar of
meetings to try
and avoid half terms as for the timing
of the meetings that should be a
separate subject and i'm more than happy
for that to be brought up
but i think we are trying to compare
apple's repairs on this issue
um but saying that you know there are
various issues i i've got caring issues
as well
um even though my my my children are
older i've got a disabled son
who's uh who has we have to look after
um
especially um during curve which was was
quite challenging
so i fully understand people's concern
family-friendly policy
uh today it wasn't meant to be a
flippant comment it was trying to show
concern that we tried to
make the meetings as possible to avoid
school holidays
and half them so hopefully that would be
appreciated but i do take into account
that
people have concerns about the timings
of the meeting so
um i'm sure that can be discussed uh
earlier today
um hopefully
people will know take this is
non-contentious side and support the
recommendations thank you
thank you councillor trump uh i think
indeed it is non-contentious that we
have
the calendars agreed the second one
obviously is a draft calendar
um in respect of 22 23
so on that basis i think those
recommendations
are approved because nobody else has
indicated in the chat
at all recently to speak to this item so
moving on now to item
11 minute 403 the treasury management
strategy mid-year review
2021 and i invite councillor harvey
finance and assets portfolio holder to
introduce this
item thank you mr chairman
at its meeting on the 7th of december
2020
the cabinet considered a paper that
reviewed
the management of the council's treasury
management function
as required by the relevant cipher code
of practice
the seven areas addressed by the review
are set out in minute
403 on the basis of the cabinet's review
i ask that the cabinet accepts the
recommendations set out in that minute
notably that the 2020-21
treasury management strategy mid-year
review
including the treasury activity detailed
at
5.1 to 5.4 of the agenda report
be noted thank you chairman
thank you councillor harvey excellently
done i call upon a seconder
councillor jefferson uh you wished a
second
i do indeed wish to second uh chair
thank you very much indeed councillor
jefferson uh
i shall pause to see if there's anybody
makes any comments other than that
we shall be taking that as an agreed
recommendation to council
and approved
uh no comments in the in the chat apart
from
accounts of fielding making some
comments there
apparently you can't see me i think but
never mind
we have agreed that item uh
minute 403 that recommendation to
council so we'll now move through to
item 12 on the agenda minute 404
notice of motion declaration of
biodiversity emergency
and i invite councillor pemberton as
deputy leader of the council
to introduce this item thank you very
much
chairman um members will be aware that
uh a motion was brought
to full council uh in the names of
councillors junior and pertiguella on
the 19th of october
to call for the declaration of a
biodiversity emergency
at the meeting of cabinet on the 7th of
december cabinet considered very
carefully
the officer's report in relation to
the notice of motion the
recommendation that was accepted and the
recommendation now to council
is that the council continue with its
existing plans
and programs relating to biodiversity
across the district
including through the actions endorsed
following the climate change emergency
declaration
and that our biodiversity emergency not
be declared
and that the second recommendation is
that the notice of motion
be rejected
i would make a number of points
just to help members in relation to the
consideration
that a cabinet gave here
the first and the fundamental point is
that this council
has declared a climate emergency this
council has
um subsequently um in
all its utterances and all its intents
made a commitment to the climate
and therefore it is in that context that
we considered a number of
issues officers looked at the potential
reasons
in favor of declaring a biodiversity
emergency
they identified the possibility of
creating a biodiversity
plan cabinet and i considered that
and in real terms felt that would be a
duplication
of work that is already underway there
will be a climate emergency action plan
developed to everybody
out of this room it seems
absolutely clear that the only way
that we can achieve our overarching
climate change goals
is to ensure that biodiversity is
protected
that all environments are protected
animals and species are protected
and therefore it was felt that this
would be a fundamental part of an
existing piece of work
officers also considered opportunities
to
use the declaration of a via diversity
emergency to support
lobbying and regional and national level
officers could only find that that
might or may provide more leverage so
that was at the margins
our lobbying and
efforts will not be diminished
nor will they be enhanced again by the
declaration of an emergency
um there was the question considered of
whether funding opportunities might be
lost
in the absence of declaring a
biodiversity emergency
once again there was no evidence that
that would outcome would be
the case no evidence could be found that
a declaration of an additional emergency
would enhance our opportunities to seek
funding
and finally officers considered whether
the declaration of a biodiversity
emergency would
help in raising awareness and cabinet
considered whether there might be
enhanced opportunities through publicity
but
came very firmly to the view but the
public won't see the difference between
a climate emergency
and a biodiversity emergency or the next
emergency that could be for
you know wildlife or or endangered
species
people see the need to take action
around climate change and understand
that that
involves a myriad of different facets
including biodiversity so overall having
considered the matter in
some considerable depth and through the
prism of being an authority that has
committed itself
to declaring and following through on
tough actions
to deliver on our climate change
promises it was felt that
there was no additional benefit by
declaring a biodiversity emergency
members of cabinet were also acutely
conscious
of the bandwidth issues facing this
organization
um and that it would actually be
counter-productive and could actually
impact adversely on our
ambitions around climate change to
uh dilute the efforts of our
officers by being sent down a fairly
what might in some quarters be
considered a niche rabbit hole
we need to be strategic we need to speak
sweat the big stuff and the climate's
the big stuff
biodiversity is part and parcel of it we
don't need
two three four five additional um
emergencies to be declared to actually
get on with the job
members i would actually be seeking a
seconder for my
uh recommendation to cancel that the uh
given the work that we already have
underway
that the notice of motion be rejected
thank you
thank you councillor pemberton before
calling on the second is we have uh
uh two uh councillors have requested to
speak
uh councillor juned first um
actually um i actually did not call for
a biodiversity emergency in the original
motion
so i am disappointed with the response
of the motion whilst climate change is a
key element
of biodiversity loss it's not the only
contributor
and tree planting is not the only
solution
the nppf the national planning policy
framework
requires planning policies that support
biodiversity but the current proposals
from the white paper on planning reform
will as it stands and this is supported
by
every environmental and wildlife trust
across the country
leave nature and biodiversity less
protected
with no meaningful safeguards so i
wanted to adopt this motion to counter
this
that we could say to government that we
value environmental safeguards and green
spaces
and then we recognize what is valuable
to our communities and for biodiversity
the local green space designation is
available under nppf but is not being
sufficiently used
we are not also having had criticism
this week from the climate change
committee that
measurable targets and standards are not
being properly used across the country
and that we need to have a strong basis
for the lobbying government
and also that we also need to raise
awareness of what remains to be done
near half of all species in the uk are
in steep decline
less than five percent of land is
protected and in a good state for nature
the uk has only 13 of land area covered
by woodland compared to 43
across the rest of europe and as i said
the climate change committee
this week just published a report
calling for more ambition
for areas of rewilding as well as green
open spaces for biodiversity and for
health benefits and
community well-being so even with
current planning regulations
in this district many local wildlife
sites have been damaged or destroyed in
the last 10 years
just when we should be improving the
range and number of wildlife sites
as an important objective with effective
design principles
management and monitoring requirement
in addition district council actually
owns a manager's land
for there are things being done to own
and
to manage the land in a in favor of
biodiversity but not sufficient
and i believe that emotion such as this
would assist with funding and grant
applications
to make sure that we have do manage that
land
more effectively for biodiversity local
investment in biodiversity has also been
found to contribute to economy
including by attracting visitors and at
a point where we need
more tourists and more visitors to this
area we need to make
give them something to come for it
provides an attractive area
contributes to local health and
well-being and
this is for the good there i did not
again repeat i did not
ask for a climate change emergency i did
not ask for
a huge amount of extra effort i wanted
to make sure
that this district council placed its
principles on the line
when it came to biodiversity our motion
asks that we lobby government
for the initiation and development of
existing council policy
provide leadership and ensure that the
core
strategy which we are in told is going
to a cover climate change
properly enables government requirements
for net gain policy and seeks more local
green spaces
even that the environment bill is also
coming in and i believe that
some of the things that i am proposing
are actually going to be in that there
that councils will have to take into
consideration
i think that this is timely the timely
motion and i do hope that you will
consider supporting the others
thank you thank you councillor junaid uh
councillor fertiguella has requested to
speak
yeah thank you thank you very much yes
so there are measures in place as part
of the climate change program
such as tree planting however these are
not sufficient to enhance biodiversity
i know we are not doing enough um
locally
um the further the designation that we
asked for
the the local green space the
designation is missing
from our current core strategy means
places that should have been protected
as local green spaces are now included
in the preferred options of the site
allocation plan as housing sites
as we've seen and are seeing we bought
miami woods and
borough green and elsewhere are local
planning policies not working
effectively
to protect and enhance biodiversity
the motion as for the designation of
local green space is to be included
in the next course strategy so that
that's not extra work because
i'm i'm assuming that that would be done
anyway as part of the next
strategy review or the joint land plan
so otherwise there could be future
spaces
such as these in your worlds and
divisions which will be lost to build
development
with the fragmentation and destruction
of wildlife and the loss of places for
our communities
so the uk biodiversity indicators 2020
report
which was published in october shows a
deterioration of uk
habitats and a decline in priority
species and in particular
farmland and woodland birds have
declined steadily
the red list for british mammals was
produced by the mammal society for
natural england and also for the joint
nature conversa
conservation committee and has included
the hedgehog
at the and the waterfall a species
vulnerable to extinction
so these are our local wildlife species
these are species
that are in our woodlands in our in our
farmland
in our hedgerows but the disappearance
and fragmentation of their natural
habitat are the main
causes of the decline of these species
hedgehogs in particular have decreased
by about 46 percent
over the past 13 years and again lots of
woodlands and hedgerows have also caused
the dorm ice population to decline
so i hope that you all agree we must
safeguard
our wildlife habitats and enhance and
restore nature in our district
the motion will do that let's also
remember that a healthy biodiversity is
important
important for our food production by
encouraging
pollinators and also contribute to
cleaner water and air
so with this motion we will be able to
put in place a local biodiversity plan
part of the next course strategy
we could commission an audit of all wild
places
in the district in our worlds and look
at the state of biodiversity
and um so that then we can act on it and
indeed the council could explore
across the district or even a cross
county nature recovery partnership
so i hope that you can support us in
this motion which is very important
um to safeguard our ornate our natural
environment
thank you
thank you counselor for together um i
must admit there's
been a lot going on in the chat and i'll
ask mr buckland to speak first if i may
yeah thank you chairman and i just want
to address the uh
comment in relation to biodiversity
emergency and then council june is
absolutely correct
when the motion was presented to council
it wasn't done under the banner a
biodiversity emergency
um i think it was have been interpreted
that way in the preparation of the
report back to canada so i apologize for
the confusion that that will have caused
um i'm confident though the report that
was addressed to kevin
that didn't address the the issues
raised within the biodiversity
um noticed motion last weekend but yeah
the the word biodiversity
measured emergency wasn't included in
the notice of motion
thank you chairman uh thank you mr
buckland
uh councillor flightcheck you've
indicated a wish to speak
uh thank you chair um yeah i'm just
really perplexed but what
what why the cover didn't make that
decision i've read the reasoning behind
it but
they they appear to have an inherent
sense of detachment from nature as far
as i can say
um it started this this this whole
biodiversity thing is
start of a six it's the sixth must
extinction event
um humans are a product of the natural
world
we're degrading the environment
council of pemberton is conflating the
two
issues climate change is completely
separate to biodiversity
and if the public are not aware of it
then it's our responsibility to educate
through public policies
like um like this one so
obviously i won't be supporting the
cabinet on that
thank you
uh
uh councillor rock uh is next i think
uh thank you chairman something very
peculiar has happened to my screen here
i don't know if it's happened to other
people but
uh could i just come look before
it appears that council cargill may be
sharing his screen um
so council hardly if you could stop
sharing your screen that'd be much
appreciated
thank you sorry counselor
thank you thank you chairman um well
uh catholic is just a few things that
i might have said but um uh i just
wanted to pick up
um a couple of things that uh councillor
pemberton said
uh he said we we don't want to deal with
the small stuff
well um
some of the small stuff i'm interested
in uh
i'll take an example of light pollution
when i was on this council before we
tried very hard to avoid light pollution
in the interest of both nature
neighbours
dark skies and so on we seem to have
lost all that
so when a planning application comes
along and i'm worried about light
pollution interfering with
owls and nocturnal species i'm told that
it cannot be considered because it's not
relevant to planning
well if that's not relevant to planning
where we're interfering with nocturnal
species
one wonders what we are doing so we're
losing these nocturnal species
we've got a rural uh environment here
and i just i make that point as a small
example
of why we need to control all those
things and
i am concerned as to why we seem to be
answering a question which is not the
one that was asked
the motion put forward five points which
i would have thought any reasonable
person who's interested in
uh biodiversity and presumably
preserving our imp empire environment
would think we're reasonable
and that's the question that's being
asked and i think
unfortunately we we're now being asked
to vote on a question that wasn't asked
and i do find that slightly disturbing
thank you chairman
thank you councillor rock uh councillor
adam i have next
thank you chairman um i suppose it would
be remiss of me
to um refrain from speaking about hs2
when we're having a conversation about
biodiversity
this is a massive um impact
in my ward and uh in neighbouring wards
that is
frankly tearing up the countryside and
various habitats as a result
um in response to councillor pemberton's
assertions that
um the public don't seem to be able to
understand the difference between a
climate emergency and a biodiversity
emergency
the people i speak to especially who
those who have
particular concerns about the horrendous
destruction of our
agricultural land um as a result of this
project
are very well informed and very um
informative to to me when when
addressing this exact topic
so i think frankly the the lack of
understanding seems to come
from him on this and um i
i think the fact that we are seeing such
a horrendous bit of devastation in our
district
means that we need to be as robust as we
can as a council in leading on it
thank you council adam next i have is
councillor jenny frankly
thank you chair um i agree with a lot of
what has just been said i don't repeat
it just like to point out one thing
the county council has done a
considerable amount of work
on uh biodiversity and have actually
developed a scheme which i think is
unique in the country
whereby offset can be achieved
on planning applications which can
provide money
to make sure that biodiversity is
maintained within a development
or actually takes place elsewhere if
if the development can't actually take
it forward
it seems to me uh and actually to in
order to achieve that
a biodiversity uh audit has to be
undertaken
we actually need to take biodiversity
extremely seriously because this is
one area where a county has actually
developed
a mechanism quite a small area i do
admit that has developed a mechanism
by which biodiversity can be improved in
the uh
in the district and in the county thank
you
thank you councillor frankly
i've got councillor cargill next and
about half a dozen more people after
that
thank you chair i will be fairly brief
um
council project mentioned what did we
get
when we're discussing this at cabinet
we've got it all we do understand it
we're not immune to what's going on
around us
i'm a country that i've been born and
bred in the country i know that i work
with farmers
and in the environment we understand it
very very well indeed
we also understand what's going on
around us we are seeing a lot of
diversity we're seeing it through a
building and
and that's one of the main things that
we've seen for that it is climate change
as well
and i just feel that we must try and not
dilute the message that we're trying to
get out there it is
it is an environmental emergency over
all it's not just or separating them out
and i and that was one of the reasons i
wanted to actually say
let's focus on that i don't want to
dilute the message
also i don't want to look at the
resources of our officers as well
and at this moment we are stretched
there's no date about it
i would like them along with our
colleagues now in
warwick to focus on the core strategy
and that is where we can start to build
in these safeguards
that we're talking about today and it is
important it's vital that we get this
right we all want
as a environment that we can be happy
with
and pass on to our children as well
can i just pick up one of the little
thing on trees in woodland please
i along with other people want as much
woodland as we can and
and i think it's council junit said that
yes we are
low in this country for woodland and i
get that i think that's
england as opposed to the united kingdom
and i am
in in conversations with many people
over
replanting or planting in particular
areas but i just like to pick up one
point as well and that's the difference
between planting for woodland and
harvesting wood
it is completely different woodlands are
planted to be harvest
trees have a life they have to be taken
down after a
particular time when they're ill or or
whatever and there are certain things
like this
you must get that that concept right
because
i don't want this everyone to think that
just every woodland has to be protected
they are there for various reasons we've
got one literally just up the road for
me i'll walk it
three four times a week and it's
beautiful but it's a managed woodland
and it's so important that we don't lose
sight of that
the planning white paper i think
correctly find wrong has now been
uh pushed back a little bit and that
gives us an opportunity now to get our
course strategy in place as well okay
i'll go back to that
point again so just to say that i don't
want to
dilute the message that is one of the
things we talked about at cabinet
it's absolutely vital we do get it we're
not immune to it please don't think that
for a moment thank you
thank you councillor curtis uh
councillor
beggar pardon uh that was councillor
cargill councillor curtis is next
thank you very much chair um
i found councillor pempton confusing
uh maybe i'm i'm the only one and i i
was in the dentist chair for quite a
long time so i'm not entirely with it
sometimes it seems to suit him
that he says the residents can
understand
complex areas the complexities of waste
management
yet they fail to understand the
difference between
diversity and climate change
biodiversity and climate change
i think residents can understand both
those concepts extremely well
climate change may actually
almost be too abstract and too vast and
i think
many people feel sort of paralyzed in
the headlights if you like
um you know unable to to do anything
about climate change
but residents will understand and they
can
grasp the concepts and the importance of
biodiversity
because it's personal it matters to
them and i believe that residents
should really be supported in protecting
their
own environment where they can see the
impact on biodiversity in the ground
whether it says councillor adams pointed
out in response to the hs2
devastation or also in the council of
patagala's
area in mayan vale woods people can
understand
and it is personal it should be personal
and that's where i think focusing on
biodiversity is absolutely essential
thank you chair
this is i have uh councillor fielding i
think is next
thank you chair i remember when we had
this
debate on climate change
no sorry it was green bins um i
referred to the fact that we ought to
allow our gardens to be too tidy
by doing that we were preventing
wildlife
hedgehogs and everything else now it
seems that
we we're all in favor of it there's
also the problem that the uh
department of environment and the what
was the
men of ag are now actively pushing
farmers with grants
to start planting borders
with wildflowers to allow all the
diversity that we need there's also
schemes to make hedges a passageway for
i think there's a lot going on and we we
as a
as a council yes we should be looking at
it but there are a lot of things that
within this climate change problem that
we have
we've got to look uh at encourage
people in the in the area to deal with
it there's also
work going on at the moment with the
cotswold aonb
about dark skies that's been headed up
by somebody in my ward
and um you know there are important
things going on that we may not be aware
of
therefore i don't look at it as an
emergency i look at it as a problem that
we will take time to sort out and it
shouldn't be rushed
otherwise they're just going to a lot of
expenditure
and possibly wasted
i think your cats the fielding
councillor tony jefferson please
thank you chair uh i think it is
terribly easy
to declare emergencies
in the real world there are an awful lot
of trade-offs to be made
i mean council adams raised the issue of
hs2
decided on nationally as a major
infrastructure project
do we have any real sale control over
that the answer is no
if you want a major infrastructure
sometimes
that has a lot of implications so the
reality actually is
you've got to make choices you've got to
make
balance